[Music]
gentlemen let me start by saying let me
start by saying how much I enjoyed your
movie it's you guys did a great job with
this script but before I get to ask you
a whole bunch of questions
the only reason Collider gets to be at
the Toronto Film Festival is because we
have sponsors I want to give a huge
thank you to Nordstrom Canada for being
an awesome sponsor and allowing us to
cover movies like Dolomites thank you
jumping right on in I hate asking the
the the generic but let's go backwards
and say how did you two land on this
project and writing it about 16 years
ago we got a phone call saying that
Eddie Murphy one wanted to meet us and
we're like yes that sounds great so we
went over to meet Eddie Murphy and we
walked in and he started doing lines
from a film he wrote called ed Wood and
he was like doing all the characters and
he was it turned out he loved loved
loved Ed Wood and then he looked at us
and said you guys know who Rudy ray
Moore is and we're like yes we know who
Rudy ray Moore is because we were
obsessed with Rudy ray Moore in college
like Scott actually like bought me VHS
is for for my birthday present when when
the Rudy movies hit VHS in the 80s we
had all the movies and we we would watch
the especially the human tornado trailer
over and over and over and over and
shout out all the lines so yes we knew
Rudy and got obsessing so we were like
Rudy ray Moore and Eddie Murphy
absolutely that sounds like the greatest
movie of all time
and so then Eddie said let's try to do
this and suddenly in a week later we
were in office with Rudy ray Moore and
we spent the day with Rudy and he's he
sort of talked about what he'd love to
see in a movie about his own life and he
was excited about Eddie playing him and
it was very nice and we were really
excited and then it didn't happen
because that's that's Hollywood it's
like not everything works out and then
flash forward a hundred years and after
People vs OJ we sort of had had an
opportunity to do something special and
we had the opportunity to
the band back together for dole mate and
reached backed out to Eddy and said you
know are you still into it and he's like
absolutely I'm still into it and reckon
it pause there so people at verse Oh Jay
big hits yes everyone's talking about it
yes so what exactly happens there you
have something like a producer financers
or coming to you saying well no when you
have a when you have a hit of that size
you kind of have that ability to people
when you go into an office if you have a
strange idea they're not gonna instantly
reject it they're gonna be like yeah but
they used your clout and then and then
we were talking to producers John Davis
and John Fox and John says well let's
just call it Benny right now like really
so he just calls it Betty and then a
couple days later were sitting in a room
with Ted serranos at Netflix yeah and
then they bought it I mean it was just
kind of crazy and we said Wow okay well
good for Netflix that after all these
years they just say yes this is a really
cool movie and it turned out that Ted
serranos had run video stores back in
the 80s when Rudy was hitting on VHS so
he was totally familiar with the movie
right we thought we'd have to bring him
up to speed about who Rudy more was and
not at all he totally he'd totally
I think Rudy Ray has a bunch of secret
fans like people who like you know think
that they're the only person who knows
RiRi more but they then they treasure it
here's the thing though Eddie has
famously said many times he loves just
sitting on his couch so I mean this he
yes he said that and I guess it's true
to do this project we broke the cardinal
rule that the principal-agent in our
lives gave us 2530 years ago which was
30 years ago which was boys never write
for a star never never never write first
star and he told us all these horror
stories like back in the day from CAA
you know back in the early 90s where
people would you know would just spend a
year of their lives writing for one
movie star that was attached to that
movie and then the movie star would
never read the script right and then the
script is dead and so in our entire
career we've never written for a star
and for Eddie we made an exception
because after meeting with Eddie and
sort of seeing the excitement in his
face we said oh my god he will kill he
really wants it it'll bring him back in
a big way and so we decided we never
told him on this that we didn't care
what anyone thought of the script except
for Eddie yeah we were writing a script
for one person because if Eddie loved it
it's a movie and if Eddie didn't love it
then no one's gonna make a movie and it
was a movie we wind the sea I mean the
idea of Eddie Murphy playing Rudy ray
Moore and yeah I was watching you at
this screening last night and like you
were laughing at all the lies and that
he wanted a movie I'm that sad
screenwriter last at his own jokes but
ya know it's a movie but you know this
is this is if you would have told us
when we were you know when we were
sitting on the couch in college watching
these movies that someday it was going
to premiere we're gonna make the movie
and come here at the Toronto Film
Festival and star one of the great icons
of screen we wouldn't believe it and
yeah we were just living in a house with
a bunch of schlubs and silver like six
guys in one house for $1,200 a month
yes that's how crappy that house was and
we would just spend the afternoons
watching dolomite and flash-forward
almost holy [ __ ] 35 years and now it
says wonderful movie with Eddie the
other really gratifying thing about this
was that you know 16 years ago when we
met with Rudy ray Moore we told him we
were gonna tell his life story for the
screen and then it never happened and
then Rudy passed away and there was a
sense of like obligation we always felt
that we'd you know we kind of let this
guy down and so be able to label
actually make the movie and I think Rudy
would be so proud of this film
ya know I I know a hundred percent yeah
absolutely
so you you're writing the script you
know you have to get Eddie and if you
get Eddie the movies made so when did
Eddie say at what point did he say oh
and when we were writing this script we
were putting in lots of secret Easter
eggs
they were just ready just like little
sprinkles of seventies culture and
comedy club culture and that and stuff
from like comics on the chitlin circuit
that we weren't sure anybody else would
get these
references but we knew Eddie would we
knew Eddie would know who Wildman Steve
was supposed to yes my question is so at
what point does you actually show him
the script is it in a rough state no no
no no final draft no never yeah we never
show people it until we feel it is till
we feel it's ready to go to the big
screen I mean we'll bounce it back and
forth our wives can read it our friend
can read it yeah friend Dan waters who
wrote the movie heathers he's alright
he's our he's our guy that little circle
got to read it a couple times but no it
doesn't go in until it's ready to shoot
okay so you have a finished script that
you're super happy with you hand it to
Eddie right how long before Eddie
actually contacts you again I was Monday
it was a Friday - oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
no I mean here's the thing it's not you
know we're Eddie Eddie was waiting right
he won it for 16 years he wanted to make
this movie the fact that we said it once
and we did it again I mean he just
wanted this movie so we we never felt
like he wasn't a part of it and so he
was ready to go and he just said yes I
mean well it was it wasn't it wasn't a
sense we had to be hope we had to catch
him again we had him and he and he loved
the script and he reacted to our writing
so you have the finished script or is
that so Ted and Netflix have already
agreed to make it or owns it they're
paying so okay and then and then you
know Eddie's there and then it's like
you got to get a director and you then
you start casting and you know at any
point a taking a regular studio you
could boys back out but naturally you
always incredibly supportive we've had
movies fall apart when they're yeah
already cast and crude yeah two weeks
before they shoot so yeah that happened
a car planning so until the first day
production you never know yeah sure
so you man I'm trying to analyze it's
such an amazing process
what is the obviously you're telling
you're making you're trying to tell an
honest true story about Rudy and all the
players but you're also making
movie so talk about balancing that line
of you know fact and fiction and healthy
telling the story I mean we we we don't
like to make up [ __ ] we try to keep it
as truthful as we can we love research
we love details we love putting in weird
facts and I mean like for example this
in this movie we really fell in love
with the sort of the chitlin circuit and
they hold making of the x-rated albums
that we felt that was something that
we'd never seen on screen before people
don't know anything about yeah that
world yeah yeah I'm it I mean it's
basically gone now but but there was
this whole circuit running through the
deep south and going up the northeastern
seaboard up and up until New York and
then if you hit the top it was the
Apollo Theater and it was black theaters
for black audiences with black
performers and Rudy you know was sort of
downing the lower rung of that a lot of
them are just storefronts or barns and
Eddie's to say hey hey I don't even
think he got to the chitlin circuit he
was on the rice and bean circuit yeah
yeah yeah and so the idea that you know
Rudy you know went to a record printing
plant printed his own records glued the
labels on made the covers and then put
them in the back of his car and then
drove around the South song them out of
the back of his car and doing these
one-nighters it's like wow this is
really interesting it's a world we've
never seen in a movie and it's what we
really loved about the whole Rudy story
is a sense of duty yourself this guy was
somebody that that that you know record
companies and movie companies never gave
a break - and he nobody ever reached out
- yeah so he was a guy just refused to
take no for an answer and created his
own little industry off to himself Mike
Epps in the last interview said he was
basically Tyler Perry before Tyler Perry
yes sir seriously it's there's very few
pretty African American performers who
were just totally did their own thing
and we're entrepreneurs and we're just
you know the the movie really shows you
how he made a business out of this and I
think Rudy was always broke because he
was always plugging every dollar back
into himself
yeah because no because no one was
paying him the other thing though is he
was doing it in a time and place people
like nowadays they forget in the 70s and
the 80s the technology was not what
technology is today to get people to
talk about things and to spread the word
it's a different piece no yeah no I mean
that's the thing that's like we have a
bunch of scenes in the movie where just
somebody rudy promoting his work like
him just driving around with a bullhorn
in car we're going to you know
barbershops and give me him posters to
put up in the windows that's how he got
the word out I mean he recorded an album
literally in his apartment and it made
the Billboard chart yeah that's crazy
yeah no I agree and that's dope but
that's one of the reasons why I mean the
movies so good is because it's an
inspiring story and it's also a really
good movie and it's just everything
about it it's a I was not as familiar me
with you're not expected yeah I can't
imagine there's there's so much I'm Pam
I'm basically out of time but I'm very
curious with the the movie the way it is
was there a lot of stuff that ended up
on the cutting room floor or do you know
well the most expensive scene in the
movie got cut out which it makes me sad
just because it looks so beautiful when
Rudy was playing the chitlin circuit at
one point in one of them one interview
we saw with Rudy he referred to
performing in a barn in a cow pasture
and we thought wow that's cinematic yeah
and so our production designer you know
clay Griffith recruit created the deep
south a barn with cows and 50 vintage
cars parked out front in the dirt as a
parking lot and then inside the barn is
a full show going on the blues band and
a whole thing and 100 sweaty dancers and
it's just it was so beautiful but it was
too much chitlin circuit yeah and so
that was like when you when you're when
you're cutting a movie if something is a
clean lift if everyone's gunning for it
yeah because if there's like like four
minutes that you can just lift out and
the movie still works that becomes what
you cut out and so it makes me sad just
because it look it looks so beautiful
here
thing though and I'm waiting on Netflix
like for example I'm waiting for them to
actually put deleted scenes on that
pleasure or an extended cut because they
actually let me premiere a big deleted
scene from out walking on the site Wow
and but it's never been released like
they've never put it on a menu system I
love hopefully with that right there's
actually they're they're they're they're
funny little scenes that maybe there's
like when Rudy got when took dolomite to
the ratings board oh yeah yeah they they
didn't they didn't know what certain
words meant they're like soup eaten
junkyard is that a cuss word is it rated
X I don't quite know what to do it
literally got they paralyzed so I forgot
about that change
okay my last thing for you guys I am a
fan of your writing what's coming up
next for you guys we just wrote a thing
for another thing for Netflix based on
Phil Knight's book shoo dog about the
formation of the company Nike and the
whole shoe shoe culture company thank
you that's so when is that going we just
turned in our first draft sure Oh God
okay so that's what you're working on
right now correct well first of all I
I've heard something about sneakers and
how popular they are yes that's a very
interesting story that I'm looking
forward to seeing um congratulations on
this thing I know people are gonna love
it
thank you so much for stopping by